if she was out of my life it would be
mass suicide exactly which infers that i
have multiple personalities
that was sylvester stallone just seven
months ago saying he can't live without
his wife jennifer flavin every day is
your day honey you know i wouldn't be
here without you
but now the pair is parting ways
jennifer filed for divorce last friday
in florida and e.t is breaking down the
stallone family's most telling
confessions leading up to the split all
from the salon daughters podcast
come on you married me it had to be
something apparently laughter was the
secret to sly and jen's 25-year marriage
that's what keeps us going because i
laugh and i laugh and i laugh because
he's so damn funny is the funniest man
i've ever met but like any relationship
there were ups and downs too i just
aggravate the hell out of it yeah
exactly i've never done it i don't
really know what i do for her i mean i
she knows i would you know jump in front
of a small train i i think she's
fantastic she's an amazing woman i tell
her that everything he does i don't know
how she holds it together she's just
amazing i mean she's
but
but a little crazy coming from someone
who's absolutely nuts well that's what i
mean a little bit something had to rub
off on you and when i say crazy good
crazy good crazy yeah yeah there's a
difference as opposed to like sanitarium
nuts jennifer and sylvester frequently
opened up on sophia and sistine's
unwaxed podcast about everything from
how they first met i'm telling about our
dates i the first time you met mom i
remember honey it
and even how jyn felt stressed about her
and the 76 year old actor becoming empty
nesters with the kids leaving home it's
emotional stress physical stress mental
stress and your dad and i are gonna be
home alone
you and dad haven't been alone really
for 25 years we've always the kids have
always just been part of your
relationship right and that's a huge
thing i mean it's a big distraction
so it's almost like you have to get to
know each other again which is so so
strange before news broke about jen and
sly calling it quits the 54 year old mom
posted this pic with her daughters
captioned these girls are my priority
nothing else matters the four of us
forever
amid the divorce proceedings there are
already signs that things could get
heated in court as jyn claims the action
star is hiding marital assets
according to court docs obtained by e.t
the marriage between the parties is
irretrievably broken
happy relationship um
that's technically marriage advice okay
marriage advice marriage is long yeah
you know you're not always gonna be
happy and also sometimes fighting's good
because you get out a lot of stuff that
you've been holding in and you let it go
meanwhile jennifer wants to keep her
name and remain living in the family's
palm beach home until the case is closed
it's important to stay together as a
family you can't spend too many weeks
apart
as for sylvester he reacted to the split
news via his rep telling et quote i love
my family we are amicably and privately
addressing these personal issues
as long as the family's happy the wife
is happy the kids are still talking to
me it's all good
[Music]
you